foreign
hey everybody check it out I actually
remembered to put the starting suit
thing on today so we were like sitting
here talking about random [__] yeah
we're picking our noses or whatever and
then like well it's probably a good
thing that we didn't do that today
because we were talking about some stuff
like before the show started that
problem
imagine shirts on well they don't match
but you know they're from different
movies you know yeah yeah look at this
this actually was sent to us by a fan
Celtic Angel 73 who is in the uh
comments sometimes I don't think she's
in there right now she'll see this
though later but yeah the thing and
whether which I got black Christmas
black Christmas yeah yeah it fits great
it's totally rad yeah I always wear when
it comes to sleeve shirts that's always
wear a medium
if it's a wife beater small
that's like the equivalent of a big
titty girl wearing her [__] small
[__] well I usually wear small too well
because like I said when you have big
boobs if you have if you wear a big
shirt it's gonna hang like that it's
gonna hang and then it'll make you look
like you're wearing a potato exactly you
know like what take a sec but um but
yeah but also uh Celtic Angel also we
just got the box yesterday so we're very
excited about it uh she also sent us an
Amazon gift card forty dollars for the
kitties for the kitties yeah uh so we're
gonna buy some stuff for the kitties
they need some more Temptations and
various other things and also look at
this is so [__] awesome
look it's a Reagan
Funko Pop yeah
she's got a little vomit
because I was just like I died laughing
that is hilarious I've actually never
seen this one but like she has little
she has little like things on her wrist
like little restraints or like torn and
stuff like that that is [__] adorable
for The Exorcist so thank you yeah
everybody knows that so um thank you so
much Celtic Angels every three that is
like so so awesome Yep uh and thank you
very much for the notes and everything
like that
that you sent uh you know we were just
delighted to find it on our reports
yesterday yep now today we're going to
review
a movie sent to me from my buddy
Louis Hernandez
and it's called training day he gave him
gave me a [__] really nice steelbook
Edition yeah it's got the 4K and the
Blu-ray in it and he's never failed to
deliver when it comes to [__] movies
he knows what kind of movie I like and
he's got great taste in movies and this
one
did not disappoint did not disappointed
that's a great [__] movie it's up
there with kind of like sicario kind of
like a great [__] movie about
um a brand new detective on his first
day of training in the hands of this
senior special operative detective in
charge of you know he he's working in LA
and these dudes are hardcore all right
uh they're
the [__] that they're doing is illegal
but they're being ordered to do it by
the guys that run La the district
attorney was it the chief of police
they're telling them to do this stuff
and
the real experienced detectives uh they
they're very much kind of like they have
a lot of dark side skills uh very
predatory
very much about lies and deception but
they get they're getting this job done
and you're not really sure
why they're being told to do something
some of the shit's just like a straight
up dark it's it's illegal you know
murdering bad guys to get money out of
them
that they had stashed that they knew
about but you don't really know the
whole back story you don't know if
if the dudes that they were killing were
real bad guys was it Justified you don't
really know
um they say it is
but it's definitely illegal definitely
illegal and that's how they have to
operate and this guy gets caught up in
this and uh he's having a real battle
with his Consciousness his conscious you
know about whether or not because he's
he sees himself as becoming a bad guy
you know well I mean he is kind of
because Denzel I mean he starts out down
park with us I mean Denzel is like
technically he is the villain of this
movie like and you don't really realize
that until kind of like the end because
you real I mean spoiler alert this movie
is more than 20 years old so I don't
feel too bad about spoiling it came out
in 2001. but um you find out like toward
the end that Denzel or Alonzo that's his
character's name has pretty much
manipulated Ethan Hawke's character the
whole entire time like he was basically
just like setting him up to be like a
patsy pretty much for this [__] that he
possibly that he wanted to either a new
member or a patsy it could have been one
of the two right could have killed him
or recruited him as a new member this is
this is [__] Blood Oath stuff you
know which is
that's a lot of the Special Operations
type stuff sometimes had that in it I
don't know what it's like now I don't
know anybody that's anything special
operations [__] but back in the day back
in the 90s yeah new guys that were in
there and they wouldn't talk once they
go in there they won't talk but you hear
rumors and my uncle was in task force
160 Special Operations Aviation
two of my uncles they were brothers
but they were married into the family
they weren't blood relatives and they uh
now they're body cards and
helicopter Pilots for guys in in [__]
Saudi and
Dubai you know they worked for [__]
billionaire clients and um I was hearing
things through my family about you know
yeah is that it's not really on the up
and up all the time what they're doing
but they don't give you any details
it's um
well this is kind of like the police
version of it something has to be done
it's it's illegal they're ordering you
to do it anyway if you get caught you're
you're [__] you know
you have to kill yourself or you have to
make sure the enemy kills you you know
because you you can't see the inside of
a courtroom
um so and they're going to deny your
existence they're gonna say you're some
kind of terrorist we don't know that guy
that type of dude well this is kind of
like the police version of that
I'm not totally sure if Alonso was a bad
guy in that way he was he was doing bad
[__]
he was killing people illegally but he
was being ordered to do it yeah he was
setting guys up but I don't know the big
picture I don't know
what the stakes were I don't know how
much of it was stuff he just pulled out
of his ass or if it was a tactic that
they were using and it was evidently
this was regular tactics that they used
they didn't want good guys in this
Special Operations [__] detective
[__] they wanted bad guys in there
well his whole thing was he was
basically just um
kind of out for himself because he was
out too he was trying to keep from
getting smoked by the Russians and the
reason that he was Gonna Get Smoked by
the Russian mob was because when he was
in Vegas this isn't in the movie but
they just like refer to it
um he apparently got uh drunk or was in
a rage or something like that and beat a
dude to death not knowing that it was a
dude from the Russian mob so then the
Russian mob were like well we're either
gonna kill you or you give us a million
dollars or whatever it was so he
basically like manipulated all of this
to get that money from Scott Glenn's
character Roger uh so he wouldn't get
his ass killed yeah and he was like kind
of had Ethan Hawke because he was there
for that day for the training day
um he was gonna kind of uh use him as
like a tool a tool yeah he was going to
reward him if he went along with it but
the thing is there's some caveats to
this
yeah he killed that Russian mobster but
we don't know in Vegas wouldn't it we
don't really know
the background
it was probably in the line of one of
his missions okay well no because
um the three wise men that the the guy
like the D.A and everything like that
were like yeah you [__] that up in
Vegas like he they said he just went off
on a yeah on a tear and like did it like
stupidly because he got mad yeah but
that might have happened during one of
his missions in other words they had him
down there doing something and one thing
led to another and he killed this guy
when he probably shouldn't have but I
think he was working when it happened
because then they went and told him to
take care of it with the Russians
so that led me to believe they went
ahead and said do what you have to do to
get the money to go pay the Russians off
yeah and that included killing that
other guy so they knew he was doing this
they were basically kind of like giving
him their his Blessing to because they
needed it although well I don't know
about that because I don't know if
I mean they didn't really seem to care
one way or the other like if the
Russians killed him or if he got the
money because Denzel was just kind of
like oh well I can he said something
like well I can call it like I can tax a
person yeah like because he knew that
Roger had all that money that he could
go get but I think that if he didn't
have access to the money I don't know if
the D.A and all them would have cared
all that much if they had the Russians
had just killed no I didn't I'm not
saying that yeah they don't love him
right they might need him though he's
he's a useful tool right so don't you
know this is Mission oriented stuff this
doesn't have anything to do with right
or wrong or what their feelings are they
told him to take care of it which means
and they knew what what who how he was
they knew that that he meant they knew
that he was going out and kill people
get that money to to pay off the
Russians they knew they didn't care
and if he survived they're like okay
that's good whatever yeah they didn't
really care about it yeah yeah yeah
they're not emotional this is just this
is just Mission oriented [__] the um now
the guys that what he called the wise
men we talk about the wise men all he
does is talk about he's a good man and
all and you can see the Expressions on
those dudes faces they're like yeah [__]
whatever because we're not good man
they're all bad they were all bad all
right so
because part of his
conversational style is to [__] blow
smoke up your ass and to [__] make
you relax because he's gonna [__] you
over you know or he eventually if he has
to he will there's just a bunch of dark
cops very dark well this was kind of
based and uh uh somebody just said it I
think uh Danny Rowling just said yeah
this was based on like not
super like uh accurate but it was
Loosely based on a real cop like Rafael
Perez
and this will will the screenplay which
was in my David Ayer by the way was
actually written before I guess wasn't
there that big um police Scandal like
the crash Scandal or whatever they
called it
um and I think that this movie was
written before they found out about that
but there had been another LA Police
Scandal that this was kind of loosely
based on
um like all of this kind of stuff that
was going on in there now this is what's
unusual about this situation is that's
happened within the United States and
they're usually real hush about this
kind of [__] in other countries
law enforcement is kind of Run This Way
um
a guy that I went was in the army with
his name is Timothy vanvakius you can
look it up
he's locked up right now
but he worked for South American and
Central American clients for [__]
decades
those clients were in governments down
there and also in intelligence agencies
in different countries and it merged in
with drug cartels
and he's in prison for I believe just
attempting to kill a DEA agent I don't
know if he actually did it
but his job was to run death squads and
it was him and about four other
International mercenaries guys from
Russia guys from Germany I think one of
them was an Austrian Soldier and they
ran around dressed like cops knocking on
people's doors to arrest them and they'd
vanish them take them out and kill them
and they were doing this under the order
of the governments so Central American
governments
and they would be considered private
security contractors
not American
security contractors just whatever
country they were working for at the
time usually something in South America
or Central America
these guys are kind of like that in a
certain way but they're shaking down
drug dealers and trying to pay off mob
people and stay afloat and [__] bust
dealers but they have to do it kind of
slowly evidently and they kind of milk
it for the money and there's they're
doing it like that but if you can look
up Timothy van vac because he's a friend
of mine
we've basically grew up together in the
Army he was a good dude he ended up
getting out as like a Sergeant First
Class he was in for a long time
I kind of sympathize he was just working
for customers and it was illegal but the
people that run those governments were
telling them to do it so it makes him
wonder how many of these security
companies are like this working inside
the United States I imagine there's a
bunch of them
just we'll never know
people they probably just make it look
like suicide
throwing people out windows hanging
people
write the suicide notes and everything
it's got to be that
xanadas said I think this is Denzel's
best performance uh he's [__] yeah I
haven't seen every single movie Denzel
Washington has been in obviously because
he's been in a lot but I kind of feel
like and please correct me if I'm wrong
but I thought this came out in 2001 was
this actually the first time that he had
played kind of like a bad guy I kind of
feel like he always played like
nice guy or like you know good guys up
to this point and who knew that he was
this good at being like this ruthless
[__] he got an Oscar for this
yeah uh best actor and actually Ethan
Hawke was uh nominated for best
supporting but he didn't win but so uh
so yeah Denzel final I think this was
his first uh Oscar so he finally got him
uh finally caught a show for a long time
she's in the comments yeah she's usually
just sitting up being pretty over here
in Australia eating a lot sleeping like
a lion according to what she said
sleeping
[Laughter]
getting pretty with our new baby
slasher Fred said this movie is sort of
like what if Obi-Wan Kenobi or Mr Miyagi
from The Karate Kid were a corrupt
trainer yeah yeah kinda well I was
thinking I was kind of thinking that
about it a little bit of Star Wars
terminology terms too this is like Sith
training
you know because it's kind of like how
they would trade you the dark side or
the [__] hardcore if treat military
paramilitary units or hardcore entry
units back in the 80s and the 90s
they're mean like that you know
especially during wartime
but uh yeah he just throws this guy to
the deep end and immediately starts to
let makes him take drugs and trips
tricks him into taking Angel Dust yeah
or PCP yeah same thing and he he thought
it was weed his [__] angel dust and
yeah he was just like he was super super
manipulative right and then um
he's like oh you just thought it was
gonna be weed huh no no [__] and
um yeah that's my understanding that all
those undercover narcotics agents uh
take drugs they have to if they're not
taking drugs in front of these guys
they're not gonna be trusted well see
that's what I mean well see that's
what's really good about this movie and
I think this is like the screenplay for
this was really really good because
um I feel like you kind of even though
you know when you first meet Alonso when
you first meet Denzel's character you're
kind of like Well he seems a little you
know when they first meet in the diner
he's obviously like very rude and like
very abrasive and [__] like that but
even like despite how he is and he has
like I guess you would call them like
unorthodox methods or whatever but a lot
of the stuff he says like totally makes
sense yeah and honestly like you know
yeah you should if you're doing it like
undercover [__] like they do and they're
trying to like bust these big drug
dealers and whatever yeah I mean if
you're undercover you absolutely do have
to like take drugs because you're gonna
get caught they're gonna ask you they're
gonna know that you're a narc or that
you're like a cop and if you they know
you're a cop then you're gonna get
killed so some of this stuff so but I
like the way they just kind of like
built it up because like he starts out
like you know like I said unorthodox but
you know reasonable sounding obviously
because that's kind of the job that
you're doing but then like as it goes on
and I think and I was watching a couple
other reviews of this too and they said
this is absolutely a movie that you
should watch again like that you can
watch uh lots of times because after you
find out like I said spoiler alert that
Alonso has essentially like set Ethan
Hawke up from the beginning because I
think he even says like later on he's
like I've been planning this for a week
or whatever
um that he kind of set up this whole day
and once you know that they're like
there's a lot of little details in there
like [__] that he says or like the way
that he looks at Ethan Hawke's character
like certain times where it makes it
like a lot more uh Sinister be when you
know like the outcome of it that he's
been like manipulating him to this place
like the whole entire time yeah but it
was also an initiation
because if the idea was is that if he
went along with all this he would be a
hero in the eye they would make it make
him look like a hero in the eyes of the
force and they give get a bunch of
promotions and they knew that they would
be able to trust him because he had all
that dirt on him
because they would you just had to see
the movie
um yeah they killed they murdered a guy
and [__] put the homicide on the
Ethan Hawke character
and they cooked up a story saying that
as they entered the place
he shot the the bad guy shot this cop
which the bad guy didn't shoot anybody
okay and then Ethan Hawke shot the uh
the the old guy in self-defense
you know it wasn't so Professor they
just [__] executed the guy yeah
that's what they had to arrange the seed
because they wanted all the money he had
four million dollars
hold on hold on hold on he goes no no
you're gonna go on with us you're gonna
get a citation you're going to get a
unit citation and you're gonna you're
gonna be a hero today yeah you're going
to make sure
he thought it was some kind of test I
guess but he just killed that dude it
wasn't some kind of test well I think at
first he thought before he killed him
yeah because
dude Denzel had kind of been [__]
with him all day right so you kind of
think well is this like part of the
training is he just like wit like
actually wants to see if I'm gonna do it
or yeah you know you know what I mean so
and I think that's what was so great
about this movie is just that it's just
tense the whole way through because
you're never entirely sure like what
Denzel's deal is and it's like what
exactly his End Game and his plan is so
you're just kind of like well you don't
really know
you know does he really want him to
shoot that guy did he really want you
know what I mean so when that does
happen and like [__] goes down you're
like oh [__] now it's on yeah you know
it's it's basically what you're dealing
with is a very hand-picked
powerful
undercover narcotics
Special Operations unit
that is basically a gag of dudes that
murder drug dealers to steal a lot of
the money who are basically just as bad
as the drug dealers basically start that
off he's like you there's only wolves
and sheeps and to survive this you have
to be a wolf all that [__] is probably
true that he said and then after he was
killing somebody he's like why do you
care that I killed that guy
he'd been he'd been selling poison on
the street [__] did all kinds of
other bad [__] it was his time you know
he had to go no we don't know if that's
true or not that's what he said but I
mean well I mean he might have been just
telling him that to like make him feel
better but then on the other hand uh he
was obviously up to something Shady
because he had all the damn [__]
dollars and there was a scene too like
the first time they go to his house
where they're just like drinking his
expensive scotch or whatever and if you
notice there's such like an offhand
scene but this is what I mean like why
this is a good screenplay because
there's all these little details in
there that like don't seem to mean
anything but then when you watch it
again it's kind of like you know it kind
of all adds up
um he gets a phone call
when the the first time they're there
and all the phone call is he just picks
it up and says
um something like don't call me this
isn't it's your mess you clean it up and
then he just hangs up so obviously like
he's up to some shady [__] yeah um you
don't know of what Denzel said about him
was true like after they shot him but
you know he's obviously not a good guy
well wasn't I thought that like Rogers
got Glenn's character was he the guy
that trained Alonso
that's what they said right
maybe I thought he was the he was the
guy that trained Alonso because he knew
I mean he knew him from he must have
been a dirty cop that's what I'm saying
cops though right well I'll have him and
his like little Squad whatever he had
four million dollars he really could
wasn't supposed to have
yeah like under the floor they must have
stole it
well they were obviously like not shy
about [__] they'd even like break into
like poor people's houses and be like
hey we have a search warrant and they
would just like take money out of there
yeah you know what I mean yeah so he
wasn't [__] proud and that and then
when he saw that like near the beginning
when he sees that one drug deal go down
in like those dorky college students
just like buying weed or whatever and he
stopped them and he just put guns in
their faces and like took all their [__]
took me I took their weed he like took
all their drugs that's kind of similar
that's kind of similar what police would
do anyway to pull you over on a stop and
take your weed from you and not charge
you but they were just real rough about
it and he says if I see you back here
again I'm going to hand your girlfriend
over to the homies and they're gonna run
a train on her that was the threat she's
back there with her eyes looking like a
Dev like she was a [__] tear in the
headlights so what the [__] did I get
myself into going down to the hood to go
buy all that [__] buy those drugs
well now those were the same drugs that
he gave to Ethan hawkeley yeah
PCP like yeah and he just told him it
was weed he told him it was weed it's
not what it was but that's uh not what
it was because he's like oh shitty weed
you know what I mean it was shitty weed
it was late to PCP yeah yeah because
he's like oh [__] I was like oh that's
not weed yeah weed doesn't do that yeah
um yeah xanadas said I think it was his
first villain role I thought it was too
I mean I thought prior to this that he
had mostly only been been like good guys
some pretty good uh Gunplay scenes
fairly accurate
um
stylistically shot and certain
uh scenes I noticed that they included a
lot of the sound effects for spent shell
casings hitting the floor
uh which I think is a good touch in a
movie
although we did a lot of indoor shooting
through different ranges you know mostly
with m16a2s indoors and I don't remember
hearing it ever hearing a single [__]
shell casing hitting the ground and half
that time I was an M60 machine gunner
for all those [__] belts belts with
all the [__] links and the
cartridge casings I don't remember any
of them hitting the floor it's just it's
just everything's just so deafening you
can't hear anything
um but it is a good touch in a movie it
makes it sound
in a weird way more realistic you know
you hear The Gunshot then hear the shell
cases hitting the ground
nice touch
they were also uh some scenes that
looked like they were almost lifted out
of Blade Runner there's a scene where
especially like in the third act yeah at
the end yeah it's where uh Alonzo is
chasing down to Ethan Hawke's character
what's the Ethan's Hawk's character
again uh what's his name again uh oh
[__] no I can't it just totally went
right out of here Jake Jake yeah that's
right he's chasing Jake kind of like in
the way Roy Baddie was chasing [__]
Deckard and then we're jumping from
rooftop to Rooftop and trying to make it
on the ledges and
hanging by the [__] railings and
stuff
work in this too I feel like especially
when Ethan Hawke like jumps on the hood
of the car and then like Denzel is like
smashing into this car and smashing into
that girl like trying to get him off
there that was like a really I'm sure it
was a stunt man but it's like it was
really good stun I thought
um somebody said uh I love this scene to
Santa does that I love the scene where
the guys in the hotel Alonso to handle
his own dirty workout
I also like to scene where uh Jake got
uh captured basically got handed over to
the guys in the [__] Mexican gang and
they were getting ready to kill him and
it turns out then they found uh dude
found his cousins little cousin's wallet
received her from being raped yeah that
was pretty good I was like man that's a
good thing he still had that [__]
wall in his pocket that he hadn't taken
it back to her and the boobs and his
brains have been all over that tub is
anybody ever pushed your [__] have you
ever had your [__] pushed in yeah you
had your [__] pushed in I said I'm gonna
have to remember that
well you know okay so here's another
thing that I didn't until I was watching
another review of this and somebody that
was like pointing out like all these
little details and stuff like earlier on
in the film you know the scene where he
you know he goes to the the Mexican
again guys he's like oh we're just going
to this house like I I bring them stuff
like he's bringing them blenders and
[__] like that or whatever that they
take from people
and so he goes there he's like hey I
gotta go take a [__] or whatever and he
goes in the bathroom and then Ethan Hawk
is there Jake is there like playing
cards with the dudes and uh so he's just
there thinking Denzel is like taking a
[__] in the next room and then he
discovers that Denzel has left him there
and it turns out that Denzel had given
them money to kill him oh they did yeah
that's why because he put all that money
down the table he said do you know what
this is for yeah and then so and if you
notice earlier Denzel was on the phone
and this was again another detail that
you probably didn't notice unless you
saw it again and he's on the phone you
don't know who he's talking to on the
phone but he says keep that bathtub
clean he said so he was setting that up
right so he gives he gave them money and
then he deliberately left him there so
it's because he didn't go along with
that thing that's yeah yeah well like I
said had Ethan Hawke like gone along
with whatever he wanted like maybe it
would have been okay and like he would
have joined the but because Ethan Hawke
was like no I'm not I'm not being a
party to this and he was going to turn
the money in then he's like well I need
the money to keep the Russians from
killing me so I'm gonna just leave him
at this house and I'm gonna pay them to
bump him off which is what they did but
like I said because he had saved that 14
year old girl earlier yeah from being
raped it turned out that that was that
guy's cousin yeah it's funny that they
said there's a 14 year old girl when
she's obviously got implants
she does it well you know yeah yeah she
didn't really look 14. I'm not saying
that it's a you know 24 with implants
but now we sound like the rapist on
there it's like oh she's all a woman you
know what I mean he's like well she is
she was 24. but I mean they should have
got somebody that looks a little bit
because that girl did not look 14. [__]
no not at all [__] no I mean I have seen
some I have seen some young girls that
did look much older but I'm just saying
she there was a girl obviously implants
was obviously a stripper I mean pretty
much yeah I think my favorite
movie had like such great lines in it I
think my favorite part was like Denzel
calling somebody a poo butt ass yeah
yeah because we were watching it I had
the I always have the um the uh closed
captioning on I was like did that just
say poop butt ass yeah
check that out that's a little kid in
his diapers
[__] poo but yeah a little boy
Zach said uh it's I always find it funny
that um that Denzel want to ask her for
this because it doesn't seem like an
Oscar movie
I thought it was good it was well yeah I
mean but yeah it's not usually the kind
of movie I guess that like the Oscars
would I put it up there with sicario
would reward but but this was actually
like a really I mean it made a lot of
money and um it got like a lot of really
good uh you know critic reviews yeah
good so especially for the acting
performances which are great and this
movie I mean it just
every single D like not a single detail
in it is wasted and it just keeps on
going like it's it seemed like it was
fairly long but it didn't really seem
like it didn't drag anywhere it did it I
mean it was just propulsive yeah like
the whole time through it was like
really really entertaining and I was
like the the interplay between the two
of them was really good I think
initially it was supposed to be Samuel L
Jackson that would have worked was
supposed to play that which would have
been good too I mean I'm not saying that
but um yeah but this the the Denzel
[__] he killed it he killed it yeah I
mean he's so good in this yeah and I
think it's my favorite movie with him in
it and I think that he used his previous
uh you know acting career of like
usually being the good guy and I think
that he kind of like channeled that into
he's a better bad guy like Yeah well
yeah I know I'm just saying but he could
use that to his Advantage because nobody
expects Denzel to like do all this
horrible [__] you know what I mean yeah
it's kind of like Tom Cruise and
collateral right he plays the Assassin
similar movie similar
Ben says you thought he was my friend he
sells drugs to school children yeah so
like I said you never know if that's
true or not but like in the end
does it really matter it might be true
it might not be true but the thing about
it is Denzel well he says a couple times
during the movie too like he has this
line where he just says um you know it's
not what you know it's what you can
prove yeah I think he was just a very
gray cop that had mutated along the dark
side yeah yeah and killed bad guys any
way he could and was trying to survive
any way he could yeah it's all really
all it was and really in the end he was
kind of just trying to save his own eyes
yeah he was trying to survive you know
the Russian mob was going to kill him
and he did eventually he did spoiler
alert yeah
he gets he gets uh ventilated pretty
good take it back with the money in time
laughs
um yeah and I and I actually kind of
like that Ethan Hawke at the end just
kind of like dropped his nuts and we're
like oh well this is your problem now
bye and then
um nobody in the hood will help him even
though Denzel thought he was like King
[__] of [__] Mountain you know what I
mean but then he goes down there and
then he finds out the fear right and
like nobody liked him and so when Ethan
Hawke was there just kind of like yeah
I'm gonna shoot it there's like nah
we're not gonna he ruled him by fear and
reward and uh
kind of kept he kept that area as like
his personal safe zone or his personal
where he can come he was screwing one of
the girls there and had a kid yeah that
was his mistress yeah because he said he
had a wife and four Sons like elsewhere
so he had a parallel life going on in
the hood yeah
and uh they were sick of him because he
was just throwing his weight around all
the time
because he was dangerous and he ate
powerful had a lot of money too yeah a
lot stealing money from drug dealers so
he became kind of like a Kingpin
in uh in the hood and he found out
amongst other [__] he was doing other
[__] too and he found out that nobody
could stand him yeah at the end because
nobody would help him well you know it's
law of the Jungle they saw his weakness
and they said oh now we can turn on him
right so that's that's you know
and he was trying to use command
presence and use his voice and his words
to try to [__] get them back under
control if it was too late yeah they
were just they had seen man he looked
weak at the time so they they turned on
him
uh Ben said was this the movie with Hugh
Laurie as the internal affairs cop no
Hugh Laurie was not in this movie
uh Zach says can we talk about how
stupid it is that Sam Jackson has only
ever got one Oscar nominee nomination I
think for Pulp Fiction that is stupid
um yeah there's a lot of actors that
probably should have uh multiple Oscars
and do not but you know what I mean it's
it's just silly how that goes it's silly
how that goes yeah Ben said I think this
and several other La cop movies at the
time were heavily influenced by the
rampart Scandal yeah yeah that's the one
I was thinking of because there was one
later on that was called the crash
Scandal like big c big r big a s h
um but I think that that came later you
know I mean I think that happened like
after this had already been written
um and Danny Rowling said uh Sam Jackson
played a dirty cop in Lakeview Terrace
which was really good I've heard that's
really good I don't think I've seen it
though I don't think I've seen it though
um somebody said uh Snoop Dogg Cameo
that's right yeah well the funny thing
about it was that about it I was there's
the scene because I didn't like look at
the credits or anything like that so
there was like the scene where the guy
comes up to the window I was like hey
it's somebody trying to be Snoop Dogg
I'm like oh no it's actually a Snoop
Dogg okay in a wheelchair Dr Dre was in
it too I thought I saw him like lurking
around in the background and you I
thought that one girl was Macy Gray it
is it is you called it okay yeah like we
were watching he's like I'm pretty sure
that's that singer right it's like
what's her name what's her name and he
thought of it he was like Macy Gray and
I was like I don't remember like I
haven't seen Macy Gray in a long time
it's like so I don't remember what she
looks like yeah they had a really ugly
duck yeah but yeah but yeah that's who
it was that's what it was
um and somebody said Eva Mendes was in
this yeah that's right she she played
the um the mistress right like his
mistress yeah like yeah that's right and
uh somebody said Cliff Curtis was in
this I was like was that him the guy
that was playing like the main
um
like the what do you call it the the
main guy that um in the gang that was
gonna that was gonna kill him in the
bathtub that was Cliff Curtis right uh I
don't know who that is he's uh he was he
was on Fear The Walking Dead He's that
big like uh Maori looking [__]
no I don't remember do you remember Fear
The Walking Dead he was like the main
guy on that
okay well you'd know if I saw him again
yeah and he's been in other things too
but like I thought he looked familiar
too but yeah everybody forgot everything
about fear it's funny that you called uh
that being Macy Gray because yeah I
never would have she looked familiar but
I couldn't Place her I actually more
more recognized her by her speaking
voice oh okay rough gritty kind of voice
it sounded it sounds real cool she sings
like that yeah and then uh I just hadn't
seen her shape of her face and
everything they had her totally
ugly as [__] [__] got her [__]
looking like a dab crackhead mother of
two or something
but I was like man that's Macy Gray I
think yeah yeah you called it yeah
that's exactly who that is yeah that
whole scene was [__] up where they
went in there it's like he's like yeah
here's a search warrant then he goes and
like [__] rolls her house and takes
her money and [__] like that then as she
opens the thing and it's like the
[__] Chinese menu and that was like
the Chinese menu that he told Ethan
Hawke to take off his car at the
beginning of the at the beginning of the
movie so like I said everything is
connects to something else which is
which is great uh dating Rowling said
Snoop Dogg is a snitch that's how he
beat those murder charges okay yeah
but yeah this um
they actually shot this too in the
actual neighborhoods like the gangs
allowed them to shoot it in there and I
think some of them were in the movie and
they said uh they thought it was like
really cool they were yeah they were
like woo they're making a movie you know
what I mean
so a lot of this so I think like a lot
of the dudes were like up on the roofs
and stuff like that were like actual
actual gang members yes in the movie I
don't know if they actually have pigeons
though to like warn people about why not
just a walkie-talkies I don't know
pigeons is so much cooler though and and
well and pigeons is like so it's
plausible deniability you know what I
mean because it's like it could just be
Birds you don't know yeah like the whole
warning system I hope that they actually
use pigeons because that would be kind
of cool
I don't know I got Mike Tyson up there
raising him
that's right I forgot about Mike Tyson
oh that's so cute yeah that's so cute
all right so uh are you ready to yeah
wrap it up all right okay but watch we
gotta watch uh a haunting a haunting
tonight yeah I think we're gonna do
angels and demons that's from season
five all right and I'm I looked on our
thing and we haven't done that one
because I think we've done all the ones
from the main it's gonna end into
exorcism you know it
I yeah I can already yeah but I mean
that's okay most of them do oh so we're
just gonna have to like deal with it
you know that's just that's just how
it's gonna go but yeah so uh thank you
very much Louie again for sending us to
the movie I don't think I had ever seen
this movie but everybody told me like
how awesome it was so I'm glad that I
finally got a chance to watch it because
it was it was way way better than I was
expecting I was expecting it to be good
but it was like way way better if Lewis
says it's gonna be good yeah I mean it
was like really really interesting I got
I got I got super into it right yeah and
Denzel kicked ass in it yeah I mean
Oscar well deserved I feel like so I'm
glad he got one for this uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys have a good rest of
your weekend however much of it that you
have left and we will be back tomorrow
for haunting Mondays like I said we're
gonna do angels and demons which is
season five episode two I think uh so
that's the one we're gonna be doing so
hopefully you can join us for that
tomorrow at 7 30 p.m Eastern Standard
Time and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow